I woke out 15 minutes ago I'm hungover
let's get my ears pierced I kind of feel
like there's two kinds of people in the
world people who look good with earrings
and me I think rappers wear earrings
- bling - flats to be like yo look look
at my status look at almost money I got
I think it can look really good on some
people and then other people just look
like douchebags so I don't know how it's
gonna turn out for me I don't know my
sisters here's their Pierce my mom's
ears are pierced why not
I'm super nervous about getting I hate
needles like anything with a needle
I just want to faint I got a tattoo but
I'm more nervous about this ear getting
pierced you guys better start soon or
I'm gonna run out of this room I'm the
piercer and owner of body electric
tattoo how big are the holes only
[Music]
it feels like I'm in the waiting room -
he'll give me a big deep breath all the
way in
oh yeah nothing to it
how was it yeah that was nothing
I knew it this ain't gonna be nothing
you see this give me a big deep breath
all the way in
oh yeah that happened that just happened
yeah you filled in feel great ready if
you are
I guess I'm Ernie's I'm gonna be but I'm
not but I am but I hate me a big deep
breath oh man all the way up ah I can't
leak Larsson that little bit done job
wait you did it I like these a lot
actually
it's good you like it yeah good
placement all I need is like a rain
machine and a wind machine and a shirt
that opens and I'll be like a R&B singer
I feel like a whole different person I
feel like I'm more badass now it was
fine
oh it was two seconds there's just a
little bit of pressure maybe I'll hate
them in a week and I can throw them off
and be like this but at least you know I
tried it Yolo I got the metal one hoping
that it's a chick magnet
literally